this morning for the first time in the
world as far as i know
a vaccine against a new coronavirus was
registered
yeah and it is quite effective it gives
sustainable immunity
i know this very well because one of my
own daughters was given a dose of the
vaccine
in this sense she took part in the
experiment
after the first injection after the
first vaccination she had a temperature
of 38 degrees celsius
the next day a little over 37 and that's
it after the second injection
the second vaccination her temperature
also rose a little
but then it subsided she feels good
there you heard it today russia became
the first country to register a vaccine
against the coronavirus a vaccine
that has not been tried a vaccine that
has not been tested outside of russia
a vaccine that russian president putin
says is so effective even his daughter
has received
an injection worldwide the number of
people infected with the coronavirus has
now reached
20 million it comes as researchers
around the world are moving at
unprecedented speeds to develop a
vaccine
scientists say the earliest that a
vaccine could be ready would be
early 2021 after all trials are
completed and the vaccine is determined
to be safe and effective
those rules apply everywhere except
apparently
in russia well my next guest tonight
says that russia and china have violated
medical ethics in their rush to develop
a coronavirus vaccine
lawrence gossett is professor of global
health law at georgetown university
and director of the who center on public
health and human rights he joins me
tonight from washington d.c
professor grossen it's good to have you
on the day
if you were offered this russian vaccine
would you take it
i absolutely would not take it and i
would recommend anyone in russia
or other places in the world where
russia may try to export this vaccine
to take it we have ethical
standards and scientific standards for
vaccines for a good reason
because if we don't if we don't let
science take its course
we could end up with something that is
highly dangerous
in my view um vladimir putin is
uh taking a reckless step that
could be a gamble for the safety and
health of the russian people well what
do you make of
vladimir putin saying that his daughter
has been given the vaccine and that it
works um
and and why do you say exactly why do
you say that russia has acted
unethically
well um first of all
um having his daughter be experimented
with an investigational vaccine
is it's just a you know it made me
shudder you know as a parent and a
grandparent
to think that i would expose my child
to a an unproven um
vaccine that could have severe uh
dangerous effects is the height of
irresponsibility
russia has acted against all
international ethical and legal
standards
first of all uh you know even in the
early trials
um russia was experimenting with this on
russian soldiers who have questionable
ability to say no
and to give informed consent but way
beyond that
you know we already have eight trials
globally including in china
europe and the united states there are
currently in
phase three trials these are large-scale
population trials against the placebo
until something shown to be safe and
effective in these large-scale
trials no regulatory agency worth
assault would
approve it because it could
make covert more dangerous it could be
less effective it could cause deaths
and so it's the height of
unethical international standards um
to rush to a vaccine this is not
you know we don't want to be the first
to get a vaccine we want to be the best
vaccine we can get well can anyone
prevent
russia from selling this vaccine on the
global
market i mean i i i know if the fda
could prevent it from being sold
in the u.s but but what about the rest
of the world
well you know if any country has a
as a good government and has a reliable
um regulatory agency like the european
medicines agency or the u.s
food and drug administration they would
absolutely not
allow that drug onto the market
and allow it to be distributed or sold
in their country that would be the right
thing to do
the world health organization has
strongly urged russia to
to be slow to follow international
scientific principles
but even the who has not been able to
independently verify this these data
the institute has not shared its
trial data with anyone it's not been
published
in any peer-reviewed journal i'm just a
couple of weeks ago
there were promising phase two trials
for an oxford
and wuhan vaccine which
showed to the scientific community here
are my data
and we've said they look good there's
been no transparency out of russia
no accountability um and to compare this
to kind of the race to the moon or a
sputnik moment or to
to bang your chest as a nationalist
populist
strongman leader that worries me a great
deal
professor we know that the the fafsa is
that a vaccine
analogous to this new corona virus
vaccine
has been developed was it took about
four years um we've been told to expect
a vaccine
early next year do you do you think that
will happen
yes i do um there are now as i mentioned
eight vaccines globally that are
in phase 3 clinical trials
they've all been shown to be effective
in
early phase 1 and phase 2 trials we have
a lot of
optimism about the vaccine i think it's
possible but that by the first or second
quarter of 2021
we will see one or more vaccines on the
market
that does not mean that the vaccines are
going to be a magic bullet i really
do not believe that's the case but i
think that they could
confer partial immunity and we'll learn
you know
culvert's going to be here throughout
all of our lifetimes in every country
but we're going to learn to manage and
live with it
partly it'll be a vaccine that'll be at
least
partially effective perhaps like of the
flu vaccine
it'll partly be because we'll have
better treatments and it'll all partly
be because
people have been infected and have some
immune remembrance
of this virus but it's not going away
any time soon
well you know we've surpassed the 20
million
cases marked worldwide and the united
states
it it remains the epicenter of the of
the pandemic
do you understand why the u.s cannot get
this virus
under control
sure um we've done everything wrong
and it starts with leadership in the
white house
you know if you would if you were to ask
me what is the one
thing that countries have who've
succeeded what have they done
that the united states hasn't done and
that i would say the answer to that is
follow
science have trust in public health
agencies and have
a consistent message
that you need to wear masks and socially
distance
the us hasn't done that the president
has
personally undermined the cdc and other
public health agencies and scientists
uh in his own administration um the
public are
confused they're not following
scientific
advice to to to wear masks
to to be physically distant to have
personal hygiene
our testing rollout was really very poor
and we simply just let it get out of
control
while we deflected blame to china or to
the world health organization which i
think is unconscionable to
to put a great organization like the who
in the middle of a geopolitical struggle
that's just
intolerable i i've got about one minute
left
professor i want to ask you this race to
develop a vaccine
um do you think we have so many people
involved
racing to be the first because they see
the vaccine as being
a cash cow once it's there
you know i think it's partly a cash cow
partly it's legitimate because we're
undergoing a terrible
health crisis but a lot of it has to do
with kind of strong men leaders thumping
their chest
um vladimir putin president trump
um xi jinping in china
um so that worries me the idea of a
sputnik
five from russia or operation warp speed
from the united states
that's not the way science operates okay
professor lawrence agustin director of
the wha center on public health and
human rights
professor gardner we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight that
valuable information we appreciate it
thank you
thanks for your information too bye
you